in the lobby of Ramsey solutions John
Mark and Jennifer are with us welcome
guys how are you good how are you do
better than I deserve where you guys
from Sylvania Ohio very Lido Toledo yeah
excellent cool good to have you guys
thank you all the way down here to
Nashville to do your debt-free screen
that's right I love it how much have you
paid off a little over $50,000 very cool
and how long did that take you exactly
15 months perfect and your range of
income during that time we stayed at
75,000 from start to finish what do you
guys do for a living I work for a health
insurance plan mm-hmm and I own a bakery
all right fun good for you guys so what
kind of debt was this $50,000 that's a
lot yes there's a lot of normal things I
had a car loan a lot of it was business
debt mm-hmm yes mostly my dad but our
that yeah after we got married that's
right yeah so I'm guessing you got
married about 15 months ago maybe yep
just a few months before we got married
at the end of August uh-huh
and I started at the beginning of
October okay so soon as you kind of get
married get home from the honeymoon then
you say game on that's right what made
you know that you needed to do this what
was the what's the story on this get out
of that thing well I had bought your
book and started reading it and it
stressed me out a little bit I'm not
gonna lie put it down for a little bit
on people yeah so I put it down for a
little while and then we were dating and
I opened the bakery and built my bakery
mostly on debt and felt the pressure of
it and the stress and ameliorate upon
getting married we're blessed our former
employer bought us the FDU class is our
wedding gift oh yeah yeah we were able
to start right after we got married and
went a FPU class and kicked it in gear
there we go just like that all right so
you got weird pretty fast all right and
so uh how's the bakery doing making
money um you know what I would I would
say it's in the right direction now I'm
reading Christie Wright's book oh good
business boutique yes and
I'm learning a lot from it learning that
I need to treat my business more like a
business and not like a hobby making is
something that I've always loved to do
and I didn't really feel like I needed
to make money off of it but I now see
the importance of actually profiting and
so thank you good well Christy was just
on here last night yeah very cool well
congratulations thank you very well done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is for me I think
it's just being on the same page working
towards that goal together you have that
and you're working towards it and
focusing on that it makes it a whole lot
easier yeah the budget is really
important we were just keeping track of
what we were spending and just being
content with what we had and it was
really hard I didn't get a haircut the
whole time that we were getting out of
debt and you know I really missed all
those little luxuries but it was worth
it in the end and it helped us to get
out a lot faster
so john-mark you come into the marriage
with no debt yeah I've been blessed just
going on just cash flowing things
throughout having an old-school
mentality and then was that your parents
influence or where did you pick that up
yeah through my grandparents they were
pretty frugal and just we're pretty
conservative spent below their means
just kind of lived in a in a savings
lifestyle everyone so picture I you're
you know unusual you're weird already
and you look over and you're going to
marry this beautiful lady but she's got
a lot of debt did that freak you out at
all at first a little bit I can't lie
but at the same time I saw how hard she
worked I mean you could hear it she's
just sacrificed everything was just
totally hair on fire gizelle intense
that really kicked me into gear Michael
Luke's seeing how much she's sacrificing
it was no brainer I had to I had to
match that and more to go through it
with our Casa very cool well you do that
to get a business up and running to
start with you have that kind of
sacrifice and then you add to that newly
married and then add to that we're going
to pay off all this debt you guys have
been game on oh yeah I mean this is very
real yeah real so what do y'all tell the
people that I asked you out already what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of that is yeah
yeah to 4642 debt-free screens later but
uh okay so you guys went through the
class what was the major thing you
picked up going through the class just
being focused every day we drew a
thermometer on a poster board and saw
how much debt we had to pay off and
every morning we're seeing that
thermometer and just staying in that
same mindset watching podcast after the
class was over - trying to keep up the
intensity so terrible early on though
you had read the book stressed you out
yeah so when you get this quote-unquote
wedding gift it's got my face on it and
you're like ah this guy again he's
everything and did you have some
trepidation going into class a little
bit like what is he going to what I was
gonna do not at all I was really I mean
I ready yes oh absolutely
yeah yeah you make it fun it's kind of
like a game you know to win at money and
it was I was ready for it
cool very good well congratulations yeah
yeah thank you got a copy of Chris
Hogan's book for you retire inspired
want that to be the next chapter in your
story that your millionaires and
outrageously generous along the way yeah
so and I want this bakery to be hugely
successful I'm talking to you making 300
grand a year doing it love it profit
yeah good for you all right John mark
and Jennifer Toledo Ohio $50,000 paid
off in 15 months as newlyweds making 75
a year
counting down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Music]
well done well done well done good job
you guys and that's how it works
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]